at first scrimmage only 10 minute
quarters now we've gone 12
and a long jumper down the baseline the
bucket goodbye hero
taj run off 11 consecutive points goran
dragach
such a terrific shooter has the rebound
off the miss they drop it back
inside three is up and down
[Music]
nice pass in the corner here tyler hero
was set up shut down
the last four games he took 50
shots 49 of them were three so he knows
what his role is you're telling me he
likes the three ball
he likes it it's in his contract 49 to
50 in the paint
and finding easy baskets in there jordan
clarkson knocks down the three
right back at you comes miami 218 utah
as we roll up on the two minute mark
good job by tony bradley that time
stepping up maybe a little bit too late
on this one but the first
opportunity had to step up on atlantic
be dead
[Music]
right here you see joey
and mitchell who was so silky smooth
against phoenix
has started this game now 0 for five
olynyk the put back for two and making
up those 20 points that bogey delivered
nightly
that's right here's olynyk against rudy
step back jumper sweet i tell you
olynyk's been hot since the minute he
stepped on the floor
right here now give credit where
credit's due rudy did the best he could
on that shot
are in vogue when rudy gobert is on the
floor they are and that one means
another 50
donation to the utah food and good look
rims out
colbert's had a nice screen on crowder
jay hands it off on a baseline drive how
about that shot tough
fight hero it's active tonight
and the jazz have all found him they
have and that dunk is another
50 donation to the utah food bank points
at the half
one of six shooting they give him a two
15 now on the night
they had changed one shot before that
foul
so-called foul on gobert's fingers are
going to be twisted left and right
yeah we look at hero who's had really a
strong game stop and pop jumper i'm on a
type player
and you put tony on the floor with him
like he did on thursday night i'm
speaking to coin snyder
it is an interesting combination if
bradley can develop that
inside dragons cannot move bradley out
of the paint iguodala
gives it right back to him there's a
break in the defense olynyk double pumps
and scores
[Applause]
just a great reaction but too many steps
there's a lot of steps right there too
olynyk
found some space and then leaned in
on tony bradley
oh his toes on the line yeah on phoenix
thursday night
late in the fourth olynyk on the court
he'll drive hang it and score
is tony bradley a little late once he
knocks down the first two
he gets rolling but it's not just about
scoring for him he's working on his
passing
as well because he was able to go
outside absolutely
we knew him as a mailman powerful player
the man he had good touch as olynyk
shows his touch
was able to make some nice plays for
other people other guys on this team
that shots not going for you who can i
get open